because i think like the biggest
difference between you and us
well at least me like when you are
basically building your audience is that
your content a lot of it revolved around
fan interaction like 80 percent of it
yeah i mean yeah like fan calls and fan
mails and like reading fan comments and
everything like that and to me i've like
like i don't know how many how much fan
mail you get i probably get a lot less
than what you had to go through so like
to me whenever i get a really deep story
or like a really long piece of email
really long email um that's when i do
i'm able to sit down and read it because
i rarely really get one of those most of
the time it's just like can you review
uh school days please okay message
studio wit
letting them know that you want uh
that's the kind of mail i get most of
the time so i it's it's like i to me
it's like a it's like a nice break
whenever i can see someone who actually
has you know put effort into their fan
mail and that's that's to me like that's
why i always end up reading it yeah and
it does still like mean a lot to me that
yeah hey i've done something for someone
that i've never met before yeah or
probably never me and that doesn't
matter you know
yeah i mean some of the [ __ ] just like i
got real [ __ ] up after a while because
i was just reading this [ __ ] for hours
on end yeah it was just extremely
depressing you know because i want to
help everyone out there who's going
through [ __ ] like that but yeah you know
it's just some of the some of the stuff
i can't help everybody some of the stuff
is like i don't even know where to begin
like what do i even do to this you know
like remember one time someone had sent
me uh a thing and it was this really
nice story about their dogs right and it
was just give me the [ __ ] thing
he couldn't see off camera but ashley
was just standing with the coffees like
that
like two minutes ago while i was just
like oh god it's connor's going to get
on like a really long story right now
you know there was this uh
there was a story and i remember it was
just so the way they wrote it was like
some kind of memento-esque thing right
where it was just like i didn't know
what was coming and so she talked about
how you know these two dogs were amazing
and she's being doing a lot better
and it was like it was genuinely like a
three-page letter and it was great it
was like all positive and it was like oh
yeah so i was doing really bad in life
and it was doing you know and these i
got these new support dogs that helped
me and it was amazing and then
sorry
at the end of this thing right of this
thing that's going amazingly she was
like oh and then my dogs died after they
got hit by a truck and it was like this
two thing of it was like and now it's
not going so well but i'm trying and i'm
like
what
what i was like emotionally like i was
like the biggest bungee jump it was it
was like some kind of monty python skit
you couldn't make this up it was so
if this was a comedy show you you'd have
said the comedy was impeccably time yeah
this was so i remember it because i was
just like what and i was like what
happened the first time
and i you know it's always like you
can't help but laugh because you're like
this is so [ __ ] this is sad and i feel
so sorry i was like what is happening
sometimes you just have a moment you
like in life where you you don't know
how to react and you just your first gut
reaction just to laugh wow and it's just
like
i had to re-read it like three times i
couldn't believe it i was like wait what
i think it's just like a nervous like
reaction right
how do i react yeah you just i've never
had writing like that before yeah this
has been done in the book this should be
like award-winning this caught me
totally off i didn't even think it was
going there it was uh not a sing there
was no like hint there was no indicator
there were like characters
yeah yeah yeah yeah it was all great and
i was like what happened jesus what is
this yeah it's like it was like someone
it was almost like she
wrote in the letter like completely like
like three days and then like waited
like two weeks before she sent it and
then made like an addendum at the end
just being like oh and by the way it's
like a footnote yes being a ps
unless they're dead yes
it's not good now and i'm like
what and then this just also this is
just terrible i don't want to it's it's
horrible to deal with that stuff and
yeah it's like what what does that
person expect you to like react yeah and
so yeah exactly but you know not to take
anything away from her i do appreciate
uh her sharing that means obviously you
know that was something very very
emotional yeah yeah
and and in one hand i appreciate it but
also hand when i hear about people who
are reading tons and tons of these
letters and and they love it and it's
just like what like can you emotionally
handle all of this and if you can like i
have to like are you a psychopath yeah
like this is a lot you know it's like
imagine if you're speed running therapy
for some people like this is like you're
just like you get the stop story and you
have to get to help like they just they
leave and it's like this is horrible
this is yeah i mean i mean anything it's
it's like unfortunate that we we can't
listen to everything yeah and because
like i got into youtube because i wanted
to like just find i want to connect to
people i wanted to connect to people i
wanted to find people with the same
interests that i had yeah which is why
like a lot of the friends a lot of our
close friends in england that we had now
are like people i met through youtube or
through being fans of my content and
through that i i kind of like for the
for the longest time i kind of prided
myself of like you know if you're a fan
come say hi and maybe we can be friends
one day you know who knows and that was
that was when that was manageable right
and like some of my first some of my
first fans are now like some of my
closest friends you know one of them is
going to be like one of them every like
you know some of them are going to be
you know
at my wedding you know that's the
groupsman yeah yeah exactly so it's it's
it's gone from that to now like i cannot
you know even if i even if i'm sure
there are a lot of you guys watching out
there who i know i'm and probably you
know that we could be pretty close
friends we're just not going to have the
opportunity for that unfortunately right
because most likely just because like to
me because there's one of you because
there's only one of me and there's
literally hundreds of thousands of you
guys and it's it's an unfortunate fact
that i just had to like make peace with
and just be like you know this this is
it's part of the job is managing kind of
like my fan interaction and just
interacting with the amount of people
you can
physically and humanly interact with and
get emotionally involved with yeah and i
guess then it's like that massive
difference between someone who has come
to that realization in their career and
is able to manage it and some people who
are just like nope if you're a fan of me
you're not just a fan you're a friend
you can approach me at any time kind of
thing but then they forget that the
larger they grow and the more and more
of those fans become friends quite
unquote yeah then it gets to the point
where they're just like that's just
their entire life right yeah you end up
with people like what you were saying
that just yeah i mean that they could
have been with their fans 24 7. that
could have been me you know and yeah
there are a lot of youtubers out there
who have uh still do that still who i'd
say have
you know at the cost of their own
channel